As you can see, it's a really great neighborhood.
Oh, yeah. It's a great part of the market.
–The house has great bones.
Oh.
I'm sorry, would you excuse me?
What the hell happened?
Hit and run.
I'm never going in that Walmart again.
We supported you while Mommy was here,
but ain't happening anymore.
I told you,
I'm a private investigator now.
You're just gonna have to hustle.
I need a hustle.
No, "to" hustle.
This is the time, Pegs.
You're a phoenix, baby.
I know.
What are you supposed to be?
A real P.I.
What are you playing at?
I'm not hiring.
I'm a natural detective.
You need me, and I need this job.
Be here Monday morning at 9 a.m.
I don't get up before 11.
When I have money, we all had money.
From dealing drugs!
It was a little pot.
Maybe some hash.
There was cocaine.
Well, that was much later.
And I did it, I didn't sell it.
Oh, wow.
Okay, calm down!
Good comes from bad,
but I need that thing
that I've always missed.
I got some oxy?
No!
I'm on methadone, creep.
You don't think things are going to change that fact?
But they do.
I worry that the next time I come out here
is going to be for my sister's funeral.
Fire in the hole!
You’re at the point of no return.
The scope of this thing
could put us on the map.
What?
What are you looking at?
Get out of here.
[ENGINE SPUTTERS]